welcome to in context i'm david
bachman the election is officially in
a little over two weeks but the
reality is that the election is now
early voting has started
absentee voting has started and we are seeing
larger amounts of early and absentee ballots than  in any election in
the history of the usa and a little later
I want to talk to you about it but
first we will talk to the deputy you must
look for the turkey representing the
26th district of the state of
florida good to start what about
the possible second rescue package
financial due to the coronavirus there has already been a
package for months that there is
discussion of a possible second package it
will happen it will not happen if it happens when it
would be it could be before the election in
the intermediate period after January 20
as you see it look  we
have been
trying to negotiate with the
republicans in the senate and with the
administration since may and unfortunately the
senate gave  the back to thousands and thousands and
thousands of families here in the state
of florida and in my district and we
the speaker of the house nancy pelosi
has been negotiating with the secretary
of the treasury menus and rally they were
able to reach an agreement in march when
we passed the caps law but what we have
seen is that unless the axis in
which the chief of staff of the
trump administration has been
blocking any type of negotiation
the republicans at this moment must
not agree on what type of
package they want to present to the chamber
we paid we passed another
package a couple of weeks ago that includes that
payment another other direct payment for
families of $1,200 extends the
unemployment benefit of $600
until January 2021 we are still in
the middle of a pandemic  and I have been
talking to families here who are
very afraid
of losing their home because they cannot
pay their rent,
so the package that we  we are
negotiating includes on our part is
that assistance to pay their rent to
pay the mortgages of the families that
need that assistance and also for
the people who own these
places where people cannot
pay their rent what the republicans
want to do in  Right now is giving a
tax cut to large companies
and that is what is included in
the package, so we continue to
negotiate. I never lose my optimism,
David, that we are going to reach an agreement
because I have great faith in how the
The president of the chamber has
also been negotiating other packages,
including the one we passed in March, but
what we have to do is put
pressure on the Senate and tell them they
have to help families,
we continue in this pandemic, the
economic recession will continue and it will  It's going to get
worse if we don't send a
financial assistance package right now
so many families in need in
small businesses  leisures too and this
delay is is a political legal
logistics delay we saw this interview on
cnn last weekend with nancy pelosi
interviewed by voice may be and it left me
at least a little bit with the impression
that there are political considerations on
both sides  And also other
considerations, how do you see this topic?
We do, yes, if you see the cutbacks in the
projects that we have passed,
David, we started immediately
in March to send assistance. We sent
a package in March, knowing that it was not going
to be enough because we
communicated with all the
public health experts immediately went
to work to send another package to the
senate in May those months before the
elections we were not
thinking about what is going to happen in november
we were going through thinking about
what is happening today in this country we
need a national strategy to
to control the spread of the cover
and the Republicans and the administration
What we have seen is that they are
denying the danger that we
currently have from other countries
in our country and we are already
feeling it here in the state of
Florida, so this has
nothing to do with politics, it is what it has to do
to do with the need and with what we
need at this time due to the
pandemic that we have in this
country and unfortunately there is
no national strategy, there is not the courage of
the Republicans to say if we have to
send other economic assistance to
the families who need it  What they
want is to protect the biggest companies,
the special interests
that have been giving them all the stories
for their campaigns and such green of that
part is political but this
basically comes to the values ​​that
the two parties represent, we
are fighting to achieve  those
essentials for families for workers
for small businesses
the republicans are trying to see
what they can  happen to have
political points and protect their
special interests because it is that the coronavirus
is affecting the Latino community more
in what way you ask an important part
of the question but at the same time it is
for financial reasons it is for
health issues in particular of  the
Latino population a combination of the
two other things well there are several
reasons and look you are absolutely right the
life here in the state of florida
we
are 25 percent of the population of the
state of florida but we are now
44 percent  of the
coronavirus cases in my district and I
represent a district that the majority
are Hispanic almost 70% of the people
who live in my district are
Hispanic people and there are basically two reasons
one of them is that we have
existing conditions like diabetes like
hypertension  so the virus
affects us much more in mortality for
us
much higher unfortunately
but we are also the workers
Essential adorers in my district and across the
country Hispanics have been the people
who have never stopped working are the
people who have been working on
the farms here in South
Miami County of the people who have had
to leave are the nurses  who have
been taking care of sick people
in hospitals are the ones who drive
transportation and public roads here who
did not have the necessary personal protection
so we have to protect
the most vulnerable communities and now
we know from scientific data that the
Hispanic community is one of  the
most vulnerable communities
for young people, which is why I
introduced a bill in Congress that would go to
these communities that have been most
affected to expand not only the
Kobe tests but also to have
the infrastructure that once we
have those vaccines approved
directly reach the most vulnerable communities,
which are the Hispanic communities,
clearly mentioned  On the vaccines it is
considered that when the vaccine becomes available it
would first be for
medical workers in
medical hospital situations
and then such a situation would most
likely be for the
larger older population and after that is
where economic or health considerations could come
in.  another type that is being
done taking into account that
a complicated situation could arise from the
point of view of the availability
of vaccines and the economic context of
those who want a good vaccine and the
congress the Hispanic caucus of the congress
we had that conversation ago
a couple of days with all the
pharmaceutical companies, not only national
but international, about how they
were planning to distribute the
vaccines to people and communities
that need it the most and that have nothing to
do with the fact that we don't
have the money to pay  for
that vaccine and they told us something a little
worrying about that  these elections are
so important
but they have made me a contract with the
government of the usa with the
administration of the white house once
they have the vaccine they produce a
certain number of vaccines they give them to the
administration and the administration
decides how to distribute those  vaccines I
tell you one thing David the Hispanic cocos
is very alert to what is
happening and we
are currently working with the pharmaceutical companies
and we are going to be on top of the
administration as long as the
administration follows donald trump's air
to make sure that those  vaccines
reach our communities very very
important very important and we take a
brief pause we continue with the deputy
the payment of florida must be sought in
moments we continue our conversation
with the deputy of bimbo prison of
the 26th district of the state of florida
let's talk a little about the  misinformation and
false news that are called fake
news in the usa now
and much popularity  ad and there is a
frankly incredible amount of misinformation
and false news directed
specifically at hispanic voters
in the usa what is happening and why if
we also had all the data
and evidence that russia interfered in
the 2016 elections i am part of the
committee  judicial in congress we had
several hearings where the fbi confirmed
that and they gave us information that they were
seeing interference once again what
I have seen here in south florida
and joaquín castro in the state of texas
is that this interference has now been
Specifically
aimed at Latino communities, we
saw that there was a bit of
misinformation on social networks,
in chats like WhatsApp, friends of mine
were sending me articles that
were full of misinformation, but the
most worrying thing was when the
ESSO mainstream media, like the largest newspaper
here.  in south florida from the
miami herald and also certain
radio networks  locals were also including
misinformation so that's why we
ask fb and give us all the
information to investigate where you
are living and why they are
targeting these latino communities that are going to
be so important for the
electoral vote in november
just receive a letter  yesterday the fbi is
investigating because they don't have all the
information to give in that data
right now but because kim castro and I
are on top of that to make
sure we understand where that is coming from
but it's very interesting that it's
targeted specifically at the latino community
if they fall in the us in what's up i am
part of a group of about 300 400
argentinians mostly educated people
people of all kinds with many different types of
jobs and
memes videos images frequently appear having
to do with the choice of
false news and misinformation because  is that he
is targeting the Hispanic community so much, it
will be because with the ti  Increasingly me
the Latino population is more
important in the elections
the Latino community is extremely important
at this moment we represent
the largest ethnic group of voters
in the US in the Latino community
our voice is going to be extremely not
only important but powerful
Right now we have the
responsibility, the authority, to
influence how this election is going to go
in November
and there are certain actors who understand
that very well and are communicating in
Spanish. You know, many of the Latinos
who come to our country, David, do not
have that  alliance with no party they
are very independent they want to
have all the information in front of
them before making a decision and
that is why they are doing it just because if they
do not know where that information comes
from they think many of them think it is
true I have had  my a
Colombian friend who sends me articles that
are completely false and when I
do a bit of i  On investigation,
I see that they come from an ultra-right
that is ultra-right and they are
repeating false points that we had
heard perhaps from a website in Russia,
for example, that is, it is something extremely
dangerous. We have to protect the
electoral system of our country. We
cannot decide that not even Russia  that no
other external actor has the influence like
we are going to decide who is going to
govern the usa
incredible incredible thank you very much
we were speaking with the representative of
the 26th district of florida debbie
mucarsel cabo a pleasure very nice to
speak with you and we appreciate
your time very much thank you